foreign
this morning in the nation's service The
Life and Times of George P Schultz the
authorized biography of a man who helped
end the Cold War and was squarely in the
middle of this nation's biggest battles
for a century World War II civil rights
Watergate the Soviet Union clean energy
and most recently the Scandal at
theranos
George Schultz died two years ago at the
age of 100 but not before asking the man
who once covered him as a reporter at
the New York Times to write down his
remarkable story
so this is one of the most remarkable
moments this is in the summer of 1983
Schultz is just completely infuriated
Philip Taubman was given access to
documents almost no one has seen before
George Schultz's archives at Stanford
University
including a diary kept by Schultz's
assistant he said don't worry I'm going
to raise holy unshirted hell
go into the Oval Office and raise holy
unsured Health whatever that is yeah but
I think it was basically I'm I'm going
to have threatened to resign again
taubman's book in the nation's service
begins in New Jersey where George
Schultz grew up before serving in World
War II
following economics degrees Schultz
became a professor of the University of
Chicago teaching old-fashioned
conservative market theory
he served briefly in the Eisenhower
Administration then left Academia again
for the Nixon Administration to become
Secretary of Labor
not a predictable one the way to think
about George Schultz is as a pragmatic
Problem Solver to the point where when
he joined government he hired all
Democrats exactly and he said wait I
can't do that no this is a great moment
so you know Nixon you know brings the
cabinet together to announce various
things and George is announcing all the
appointments for the Department of Labor
one after the other they're either
Democrats or or Independents he gets
back to his room at the hotel the
phone's ringing he picks it up and it's
one of Nixon's advisors basically saying
what the hell are you doing among his
accomplishments Schultz was instrumental
in desegregating schools in the south
later as treasury secretary Schultz
resisted Nixon's attempts to weaponize
the IRS but also never quit and never
spoke out publicly against Nixon
after eight years in the private sector
Schultz was again brought into the
government fold hi George Pratt Schultz
do solemnly swear a somewhat surprising
pick to be Ronald Reagan's secretary of
states despite almost no foreign policy
experience I certainly want to approach
this task fully conscious and realistic
about the problems
but even more conscious of the
opportunities you get the sense that if
Schultz wasn't around the 80s would have
been a lot different
there's no doubt the history of the
Reagan Administration would have looked
different without him Schultz was one of
the few advisors calling for more
dialogue with the Soviet Union who
Reagan had famously dubbed the evil
empire he ran into a buzzsaw of
opposition around Reagan they sort of
teamed together to block Schultz from
pushing ahead with his initiatives so
here's one Clark doesn't like my meeting
with the president because I get a real
crack at him and the president decides
things Clark was the National Security
advisor I can take trips and that's it
Clark is so frustrating to talk to
things begin to change With a Little
Help from Mother Nature and a phone call
from an influential Ally this city was
absolutely paralyzed the Reagans were
supposed to go to Camp David for the
weekend couldn't get there
so Nancy Reagan picks up the phone on
Saturday morning calls Schultz and says
George how about you come over to dinner
with us tonight
so they did and for the first time
Schultz
had a one-on-one conversation with the
president that allowed him to really
understand what Reagan's intentions were
with his new access Schultz laid out his
vision for U.S Soviet relations which
culminated in a 1987 Landmark agreement
to eliminate an entire class of nuclear
missiles
trust but verify
the INF treaty was Schultz's crowning
diplomatic achievements Gorbachev said
the Cold War would not have ended or not
for George Schultz yeah the exact
paraphrase is the Cold War could not
have ended without Ronald Reagan but
Ronald Reagan could not have ended the
Cold War without George Schultz
in the 90s the cold war was won but
Schultz now out of Washington had plenty
of fight left in him he was an early
supporter of the 2003 invasion of Iraq
he denounced the continued Embargo of
Cuba
and more George Schultz in many ways was
ahead of the curve on climate change
solar panels on the house electric
vehicles before before they were
mainstreamed yeah you should have seen
him driving around the Stanford campus
in his 90s you know I'm not sure he
still should have been driving but he
was and he was driving around in a an
electric vehicle this was around the
same time that Schultz renowned for his
sober disciplined approach would make
one giant miscalculation when he joined
the board of Elizabeth Holmes blood
testing company theranos we're going to
move into a more and more preventive
world the company was discovered to be a
fraud thanks in part to Schultz's
grandson Tyler who worked there and blew
a whistle Schultz initially refused to
believe his grandson before they
reconciled
even as theranos unraveled however
Schultz never disengaged still showing
up for work into his 100th year here's a
guy who could have gone down to Pebble
Beach and spent the rest of his life but
he didn't why didn't he is this because
he cared so much about the country I
mean you know when you think about it
people throw around the word Patriot
these days George Schultz was a real
American Patriot
there were times when you see in the
diary when early on when Schultz was
being frozen out Tallman reporting for
the New York Times was saying things
that Schultz didn't even know so he was
he was privy to things and then Schultz
would get so frustrated understandably
but he sort of just continued on in his
steady way and then lasted longer than
any of the other cats what a work ethic
yeah yeah where are those guys now I
mean they're just long-lasting they're
they're seemed to be they seem to be
made of something that you know is is
less and less in the ethos of politics
right now different gender there's not a
whole lot of pragmatism these days yeah